[Applause]
My next two speakers I'm honored to
introduce and to work with. Uh they are
911 family members Roselene Talon who
lost her brother, firefighter Sha and
Sally Renhart that lost her firefighter
son Christian. I am honored to work with
these women because I must tell you how
brave they are in the face of the media
uh smear campaign. You know, I after
911, I I chose this fight. I chose to do
this. Uh but they were chosen, you know,
and you see if the 911 family members
that oppose the mosque, they're called
racist. They're So, it's a it's a second
wave. It's a second wave of the 911
attacks. Let me let me introduce to you
Roselene Talon and Sally Regan Hart.
[Music]
[Applause]
Good afternoon.
It is so beautiful to see the American
flag.
Hold them up high and hold them up
proud.
Yesterday
evening, we had a beautiful ceremony in
St. Patrick's Cathedral in memory of all
the 343 firefighters who gave their
lives on September 11th. And also for
the firefighters and all the first
responders who are still suffering and
dying as a result of 911. 911 is still
happening to those men and women and to
their
families. They are still
suffering. Yesterday evening at the
cathedral, the giant doors of the
cathedral swung
open
and
flags stormed into the cathedral.
It was as though they were all coming
back. They were coming in and they were
reminding us that they died because they
were American. And you know, my brother
used to say that in the fire department
when you died in the line of duty, you
became a t-shirt. Well, they became
flags that day. And I am very proud that
my brother is represented by the
American flag because I think of all the
soldiers, all those brave men and women
who are coming back with that same
American flag draped over their coffin.
And many of those men and women signed
up because of what happened to our loved
ones on 911. So 911 is continuing for so
many families across this country.
soldiers, families who are getting that
phone call feel the same as we felt in
the weeks after
911. I remember hearing the slogan never
forget in the days following 911. And I
I I kind of thought to myself, is that
really necessary? Never forget. How
could anybody ever forget what happened
down here?
I I how could anybody ever forget the
carnage, the
horror, the destruction of our lovely,
innocent family
members? How could ever anybody ever
forget? I never I I was so wrong and so
naive not to understand why that slogan
was so important. It was so wise and so
necessary and so prophetic and so
relevant.
There are so many instances that I am
seeing around me today that are
indications that the
politicians, the media would have us
forget. When terrorist attacks are
called man-caused disasters by an
administration, it is not a man-caused
disaster. It is a deliberate terrorist
attack by jihadist Islamic extremists.
And I I I I Why aren't we allowed to say
that? I'm not
[Applause]
saying we are not saying that all
Muslims perpetrated the acts of 9/11.
But there were some Muslims that
perpetrated the acts the terrorist acts
of 911. We must never forget that we
attended a memorial today of waterfalls
and trees. We must bring back some
remnants of the destruction that
happened that day. We must bring back
the sphere. We must bring back the
damaged facades. We must bring back
pictures of those people that we lost,
not just mere
names. We must not bury the remains of
the 9/11 unidentified victims seven
stories below ground at ground
zero. How dare you, Mayor Bloomberg? How
dare you bury those beautiful
souls? Not on our watch. I ask all of
you out there today to stand with us on
that fight because we must have them
above ground as a reminder, not of the
buildings we lost, of the people we
lost. That's what 911 was about.
[Applause]
In addition to the
memorial, one of the gravest insults to
this slogan of never
forget was when we heard that a mosque
was
proposed for so near our
[Music]
sight. a a mosque on the precipice of
slaughter of
Americans. This cannot
happen. We must respect what happened
there. There are mosques all over New
York City. None of us ever did anything
no harm to those
mosques. This is not about bigotry. This
is about
love, honor, and respect.
[Applause]
There is no way that the people that are
proposing to build this mosque can
guarantee
me guarantee Sally Reinhardt, the mother
of Christian
Regenhard, a fire a probationary
firefighter and US Marine like my
brother. They cannot promise her and
they cannot promise my mother and they
cannot promise any of the family members
out here that there will not be people
in that mosque who are proud and happy
about what happened to our loved ones on
9/11. It cannot and will not be built
because I will lay my body on that
property before they build a mosque at
ground
zero. And you can take that to the bank.
Share Alamal. I will lay my body down in
front of that building. And I won't be
alone either. I will not be
alone because we will lay it down for
all those people who died on 9/11. And
we will lay it down for all those first
responders who are still dying. And we
will lay it down for those soldiers who
are dying for our freedom. It will not
happen because Sharief Alamal, you have
to know as an American what happened
here. What are you? Are you an American?
Are you an American Sharif? Because you
would know why you don't put a mosque
here. You don't allow jihadist Islamic
extremists to come here and gloat. They
cannot have their halal cooking classes
and they cannot swim.
They will not swim and they will not
celebrate their culture here. Not here.
Anywhere in in America, anywhere in New
York, but not
here. This is a special place. My
brother Christian
Reaganard, my brother Sean Talon would
have saved
Muslim, Jew, Christian, Hindu. It didn't
matter what color, what shape, they
would have put anybody on their back and
brought them down. That's not what this
is about. But the media would have us
feel like bigots and and and when we
talk about jihad that we're not allowed
to mention that that all of a sudden
because we're mentioning who did this to
us that that that we're bigoted. I I I
look on on that as being totally
intolerant totally intolerant of telling
the truth.
What about the tolerance of our American
values of honoring our hero dead? That's
an American value. That's an American
value. Another thing that these is the
people building this mosque, they're
saying that they have the right and and
you know, they're trying to say, God,
how could these people claim they're so
American when they're not going by the
right that they have to build? This
isn't about the right to build. This is
about is this really the right thing to
do. Now, let me tell you one little
thing that's so beautiful about my
little daughter. You know, it's hard to
explain to her because she's wondering
why mommy is a little angry about this.
And the other night at church, she said
to me, I I tried to say, you know,
mommy, you know, you know, I can forgive
and and and I don't it has nothing to do
with the Muslims at large, but mommy,
you know, has to speak up about the
mosque. So Judy in her innocence said to
me and so eloquently said, "Mommy, I
understand because you want these people
to do the right thing like you want me
and Shawn to do. It's it's just about
doing the right thing." And and I it's
so simple. So, I I am so pleased to see
all of your faces out here and I it's a
hard thing to do. You know, it's a hard
thing on 911 to come up here and and and
talk to all of you because we've been
through such emotions today. But there's
no better place to be than speaking up
for my brother and for Christian and for
all those people that lost their lives.
So, thank you for being here.
I I I I I forgot to say this is my
mother and she lost my brother Sean
Patrick Talon from ladder
10. He was 26 and he gave his young
life and he was a Marine and he was a
firefighter. So he was a great
combination. And I we have such a friend
here, Sally, whose uh son was also a
Marine and firefighter Christian. and
she's going to say a few words.
Thank you, Roselene. It's really an
honor to stand beside these wonderful
people. You know, after 911, we all
acquired a new family and that was the
family of
grief. Whether it's the Talon family
here from the uniform services, the fire
department, whether it's Nelly Brzinski
who lost her son in the towers, we're
all share the grief. We share the
woundedness. We share the despair. 10
years has done nothing to erase the
hurt, the despair, and the loss that we
feel. I'm here today for one reason. I'm
not here for a political reason. I'm not
here to denigrate anyone. I'm here
because I'm asking the people who want
to build and the people who support the
construction of the mosque and Islamic
center. I'm asking them for one thing.
I'm asking them for
tolerance. The families of the victims
have been accused of being intolerant,
of not tolerating
religion. That is not true. This is not
about religion. This is about an already
victimized group which are the 9/11
families who have suffered the worst
victimization, the death of their
children and their loved ones. We're
asking for the tolerance of
understanding that we're hurt, that our
sensitivities are offended, that we're
already wounded, and we cannot tolerate
to be wounded again.
However, there's many there's much
precedent for understanding the
woundedness of a culture or of a certain
religion. Over 25 years
ago in
Awitz, Catholic nuns who did have good
intentions wanted to build a convent so
that they could pray for the souls of
the people who were murdered in the
Holocaust. However, and rightly so,
there were many Jewish people that
felt offended. They felt threatened.
They felt
uncomfortable by having this by having a
cross there. You know, Pope John the 23
instead of insisting that the Catholic
Church would do this regardless of who
they hurt, he had the understanding and
the tolerance to understand how the
Jewish people felt. And he asked his
nuns to please not do this. That's
building bridges. These people who want
to build the Moscow Cultural Center talk
about that this is going to build
bridges. This is going to bomb bridges
as much as the World Trade Center was
bombed on
[Applause]
911. Finally, I'd like to say tolerance
is a twoway street.
That's right. 9/11 families are asked to
tolerate the construction of a mosque
and cultural center. But I am
asking all the people who support that,
including the
politicians of this area. I'm asking
them to make tolerance a two-way street.
Right now, the tolerance is a one-way
street going from city hall to
Parkplace. We need to change that. We
want understanding. We want
sensitivity. We are not bigoted people.
We're asking for the same tolerance that
these people are asking us for. Please,
there are many empty storefronts in the
city of New York. there is much real
estate where this center can be built.
Not here. Not on the so close to the
sacred ground. Not here so that every
time we go down here, we won't have to
be wounded again and our sensitivities.
I'm asking for that. And finally, I'd
like to say so many of these people who
are supporting this project want to be
mayor. They want to run for political
office and be elected again. I want to
remind these people there's no such
thing as being mayor of Manhattan. There
are five burrows out there and the
people support the way we feel. Thank
you very
much. Thank you,
Pamela. Thank you all very much.